[Music]
in the time of the patasha emperors
the lands rad reigned supreme and govern
the flow of the empire
the land's wrath was made up of the
greatest noble houses from throughout
the human universe
when paul the trees became emperor the
influence of the land's rad shrank
by the time of the god emperor the
land's rad was no more
though the landsrad would never again
dominate the empire
after the death of the god emperor some
great houses did emerge again
and many fled into the scattering many
other organizations also sent
representatives into the scattering
traveling in all directions into the
distant reaches of space
there humankind was free to grow and
develop exponentially
strange things formed within the
scattering during the fifteen hundred
years between the book god
emperor of dune and the book heretics
sipped in
the many jesuit sisters who were sent
into the scattering eventually lost some
of the powers they once had
they joined with the remnants of later
the seconds fish speaker army
creating the honored matres they were an
order of women who maintained
power through sexual control it is
hinted
that within the scattering they ward
with an advanced
breed of play laksu face dancers who had
liberated themselves from the tlalaxu
masters
the honored montres referred to them as
the ones of many faces
this great war seems to have been
devastating on both sides
the honored montres were also in
possession of a weapon
a terrible weapon that would cause mass
bloodless death when activated
apparently much of the weapon's charge
was used up before the sisters returned
to the old empire it is not clear
whether or not
the honored matress created the weapon
themselves or whether they found it
somewhere in the scattering
considering that they do not know how to
produce more of the charge for the
weapon
this leads to me to believe that this is
a weapon of ixian invention
the ones of many faces also had a weapon
to fight the honored mantras
now you can check out this video i just
did on the differences
between the ixians and the benny silax's
approach to technology
the traelax who focused on biological
technology
their weapon against the honored
montrese was called futarus
genetically engineered humans who
possessed feline features
the cry of a futar was deadly to the
honored matres
but they could only attack if commanded
to do so by the handlers
otherwise they were docile it is heavily
implied that the clay laksu
organizational structure
quickly fell apart within the scattering
it is heavily suggested
that the remnants of the bini jesuit and
fish speakers
free the clay laksu females from their
terrible slavery
you can learn more about the clay laksa
females by clicking on this playlist
the honored matres being partially
formed from freed playlaksu females
would also seem to explain the deep
hatred the matress seemed to possess
for the tla laksu once they returned to
the old empire
the fact that the matres were said to
have fought the ones of many faces
and not the fla laksu also implies a
breakdown into
laksu organizational structure the phase
dancers were mules always
supposedly incapable of reproducing or
disobeying the masters
but clearly that was no longer the case
and there is other strange technology
that formed in the scattering
ways of traveling that no one previously
thought possible
duncan idaho begins to understand this
in the book chapter house 2
somehow he continues to see a vision of
a man and a woman
to him they appear to be face dancers
eventually the mintette mind within him
activates
and the full picture becomes more clear
when he finished he asked himself once
more about the visions
influencing my dreams what have i tapped
in every spare minute since becoming
teg's weapons master he had been
calling up archival records there had to
be some clue in all of that massive
accumulation
resonances and tachyon theory held his
attention for a time
tachyon theory figured in holtzman's
original design
holtzmann had called his energy source a
wave system that ignored lightspeed's
limits
lightspeed obviously did not limit fold
spaceships
techies it works because it works idaho
muttered
faith like any other religion mintad
squirreled away
much seemingly inconsequential data
he had a storehouse marked techies and
proceeded to go through it without
satisfaction
not even guild navigators professed
knowledge of how they guided fold
spaceships
ixian scientists made machines to
duplicate navigator abilities
but still could not define what they did
holtzman's formulae can be trusted no
one claimed to understand holtzman
they merely used his formulae because
they worked
it was the either of space travel you
folded space
one instant you were here the next
instant you were countless parsecs
distant
someone out there has found another way
to use holtzman's theories
it was the full mint hat projection he
knew its accuracy from the new questions
it produced
duncan's mint hat mine projects that
someone in the scattering must have
discovered
a new way to move through space and time
they
existed beyond a net of light as if they
were somewhere parallel to the normal
universe
or on top of it at the end of chapter
house the pair can be seen watching the
protagonist of the book
as if they are themselves outside of the
story outside of time
and children of dune lentil ii attempts
to explain
what time really is to jessica he
explains that time is not as it seems
how he asked unless you understand that
time
isn't what it appears i can't even begin
to explain
my father suspected it he stood at the
edge of realization but fell
back now it's up to gani and me i insist
that you explain
jessica said and she figured the poison
needle that she held beneath the fold in
her robe
it was the gumja bar so deadly that the
slightest prick of it killed within
seconds
and she thought they warned me i might
have to use it
the thought of it sent the muscles of
her arm trembling in waves
and she was thankful for the concealing
robe
very well he sighed first as the time
there is no difference between 10 000
years and one year
no difference between 100 000 years and
a heartbeat
no difference that is the first
fact about time and the second fact
the entire universe with all of its time
is within me lato's musings about time
imply deeper meaning to time than we
previously thought
perhaps time is malleable even had
the ones of many faces truly found a way
to exist
beyond time if so it would explain how
they devastated the honored montre
empire forcing them to flee into the old
empire
no one truly knows how the holtzman
effect operated
and only that it was effective
the ixians have not penetrated
holtzman's unification concept he said
they merely use it a theory that works
even when you don't understand it the
implication here
is that the holtzman effect has far more
potential than anyone
ever thought perhaps only lato realized
[Music]
time travel may be possible in the doom
universe at least to some extent
but that subject deserves its own video
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
hey guys you should totally click that
link in the description and follow me on
twitter